salut à toi membres de la team menthe à
l'eau oui je fais encore cette vidéo en
dehors de la maison parce que je suis
encore en date de spectacle je leur
faire honneur à une vieille habitude
qu'on avait ensemble toute l'année
d'habitude le dimanche vous donner une
explication pour essayer de bluffer les
gens pour les bleus fait ce dimanche où
n'importe quel jour de la semaine peu
importe après ça te regarde
alors c'est parti on va refaire ça
aujourd'hui je vous le dis tout de suite
on est sur du safe on est sur un truc à
100% il n'y a pas de possibilité de
rater ça c'est complètement logique j'ai
testé ça depuis quelques semaines avec
les potes à droite à gauche et la
réaction est assez surprenante vous
demandez à trois personnes de choisir un
chiffre dans leur tête un chiffre secret
le dis à personne n'y a que eux qui lui
en tête et vous demandez au troisième de
sortir son téléphone et de le mettre sur
la fonction calculatrice il passe alors
son téléphone à la première personne est
la première personne tap le chiffre
qu'elle a en tête
ensuite elle appuie sur x 2 ensuite elle
fait + 3 elle le passe à la personne
suivante la personne suivante fait x 5
ajoute donc fait plus ajoute son chiffre
secret à elle et le passe à la troisième
personne et enfin la troisième personne
elle fait x 10 et ensuite à la joue donc
elle fait plus son chiffre secret à elle
et à l'appui se régale et à la récupérer
son téléphone en même temps c'est plutôt
pratique
à partir de ce moment soit vous regardez
vous même sur le téléphone le résultat
final ça ne se crée pas d'un 10 c'est
complètement aléatoire soit vous le
demander directement à la troisième
personne est instantanément vous serez
en mesure de savoir qui a tapé quoi pour
ça c'est très simple il suffit de
soustraire mentalement 150 au résultat
final
alors si vous avez du mal à soustraire
150 vous faites moins 100 et ensuite
vous faites moins 50 et grâce aux
nouveaux résultats dans votre tête vous
allez connaître le chiffre de chacun
puisque le premier chiffre celui des
centaines ça va être celui qui a tapé le
premier spectateur le deuxième celui des
dizaines celui du 2ème spectateurs et
celui des unités celui du troisième
spectateur un exemple concret si le
résultat final ses 453 vous faites moins
150 ça fait 303 donc le premier à taper
3 le deuxième 0 le troisième 3 ça
fonctionne très bien et ce qui est cool
c'est que ça permet de bluffer trois
personnes en même temps
évidemment le présentait pas comme ça ne
présentait pas
si brut que cette explication trouver
une manière de l'enrobé une manière fun
de présenter ça ça sera encore plus
bluffant un autre conseil je vous
recommande de faire taper à chaque fois
égal à chaque étape quand il fait froid
de fou qui face à galles derrière
ensuite +3 faut qu'ils fassent égale
derrière parce que sur certains
téléphones comme sur l'iphone ça peut
créer une erreur dans le calcul à cause
de la priorité des calculs il va d'abord
appliqué de multiplication et ensuite
les additions j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu et que vous allez l'attesté
surtout provenaient ensuite là dessous
dans les commentaires et vous me
répondez comment ça s'est passé ou zid
et de présentation je serais très
curieux de dire ça et si vous êtes
encore là ce stade de la vidéo vous me
le fait de savoir laissant un pouce en
l'air parce que ça c'est important vous
pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir puisque le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31
décembre donc rendez vous demain à 17h
ciao